your mommy the babe so another
completely self-indulgent bit of video
with me talking about something that I
love and don't have any other particular
impetus to talk about it so I'm just on
a ramble for a while at this time it's
labyrinth I think that I mentioned when
I talked about Dark Crystal a little
while back that labyrinth is my
preferred Jim Henson Creature Shop
fantasy product and there's a number of
reasons for that I'm personally of the
opinion that it's a little more polished
overall than Dark Crystal was but you
know I think also it's a matter of
personal taste it appeals to me and it's
style of fantasy a little bit more than
what Dark Crystal is doing Dark Crystal
as amazing as that world was was a very
standard kind of fantasy set up and
quest narrative
whereas labyrinth while Sarah our lead
has a very clear quest angolan mine the
fantasy world leans a bit more towards
Alice in Wonderland rather than Lord of
the Rings and I like that I enjoy what I
tend to think of as fairy tale logic
which is things that work a certain way
because that's just how they work you
know magic doesn't doesn't follow any
logic and sometimes there are things
that happen in solutions to situations
that just make no logical sense but
that's just how this world works
and I tend to really enjoy that and this
does that a bit more but okay wow boy
where do we even start with with this I
you know what I think I'll start by
addressing what are some of the
criticisms that I know they exist about
this movie one of them is about Sarah
played by Jennifer Connelly there are
complaints that she is whiny that she's
not particularly well acted that she's
bland I don't I've got I mean I grew up
on this movie I've been watching this
movie since I was
I don't know six seven years old so like
I've got serious nostalgia blinders on
this I don't think she gives an outright
bad performance
I maybe nostalgia bind to that I'll
admit that I do however think that she
has a character arc she comes in
whiny bratty self-obsessed you know only
interested in how things impact her and
not anybody else and and then she makes
a horrible horrible mistake and she's
got to fix it and that is valid to me
and I mean especially considering the
age she is when things go wrong and they
go on go wrong for her a lot her crying
out that's not fair I'm like yeah
yeah that's kind of it I mean that
that's it I don't want to oversell her
she's not some brilliant protagonist but
I mean I'll certainly take her with an
understandable goal and someone who
understands the situation that she's in
over somebody like say to make the
comparison again Jen from Dark Crystal
who doesn't seem to have a clue what's
going on and no capabilities and besides
but you know set and Sara is clever
she's not stupid like the whole thing
with her marking the the ground with her
lipstick so she knows which way she's
gone that's a really good idea doesn't
matter cuz what labyrinths gonna
completely screw with you but it was a
good idea it was a good notion and she
does figure out you know figure out a
logical answer to the riddle of the you
know one person always tells the truth
one person always lies thing didn't
matter cuz again labyrinth
it doesn't really care that you that you
technically did it right but she's not
unintelligent she is clever and I think
there's a whole host of great characters
in this if you're comparing her to the
other cast of character yet she is she
is the blandest one but she kinda has to
be she you know she's blamed in the same
way Alice and Alice in Wonderland is
blend she is there to lead us through
this insanity not to be part of the
insanity herself but as far as other
characters go there's hoggle Hallows a
character i love
I have a really soft spot for cowardly
characters that it doesn't feel like the
narrative overly judges them for being
cowards I think you really do get a fair
sense of Harley like he wants to be a
good guy but he is terrified of Jarrett
and what could happen to him it scares
him to absolute death and that comes
across really well and the the puppetry
in that face is dang good its dang
elaborate it is an impressive piece of
work and I just think he's a really good
character besides and and like I said I
I do enjoyed these sort of people who
are cowards but kind of wish they
weren't and he falls into he's got so
much self-hatred being fully aware of
his own flaws and I I think that that
rings true in a lot of ways for someone
who who has an awareness of what their
biggest faults are but can't seem to
bring themselves to change them so I
like him a lot
ludo is just kind of lovable he's got
this he's got almost almost kind of a
bulldog face this sort of permanent and
he's really yeah he's just sweet he's
just sweet nice and fluffy and he's
friends with rocks who's friends with
the rocks and can summon them Ludo can
and he can do it here cuz it's labyrinth
and we don't care if you can't figure
out how somebody makes friends with
rocks he did that's how it works around
here um sir didymus I recently got to
introduce my my kids of this one sir
didymus was her favorite and I knew it
would be he all enthusiasm
it's just this little furball of pure
unbridled raw enthusiasm charge and his
steed who's like this is a horrible idea
and Brosius who just doesn't want to be
there and the two of them I mean first
of all just the image of what basically
looks like a dog riding another dog
that's just kind of Awesome and again
there's something we
enjoyable and kind of admirable about
his his blind faith in his own abilities
to just fight his way out of any
situation it is cockiness and that is
crying you see him good Ludo is gotta be
like 20 times his size and sir didymus
is reaction to thinking that he's any
used to go I can conquer this mountain
Tallyho I love that I love that guy the
goblins are great that there's so much
terrific especially if you pay attention
to the background goblins that and and
what I this is something that I've come
to appreciate more now because when I
grew up on this on VHS it was pan and
scan and this is this is a widescreen
this movie and and the crop was
basically sometimes it was just half the
screen and I was missing the other half
that would have all these other goblins
in the background doing all this crazy
stuff and great slapstick and they feel
so alive which you know it's Jim Henson
the the puppets when be handled by
Henson puppeteers always have this sense
of life to them and the goblins have
that in spades they're just funny
they're funny and they're weird and
they're not particularly creepy of
coming back to something else that I
think people tend to complain about the
fire gang which is a weird non sequitur
and an odd song it doesn't really move
the story forward but again in my mind
it fits because this this is Alice in
Wonderland if Alice in Wonderland
actually had a plot because I also want
to let doesn't really she just kind of
meanders from thing to thing to thing
and depending it's been a long time
since I've read the original book I
don't remember being a strong thrust of
the book but depending on different
adaptations sometimes there's more
emphasis on her trying to get home or
sometimes they try and bolt a quest
narrative onto it and it doesn't take
but this this feels like it's dipping
its toe into that kind of nonsense which
I love I love fantastical nonsense but
it also has her like having a mission
but if you're thinking of it in closer
towels and one
Lord of the Rings or Dark Crystal then I
might just in my mind this kind of
divergence of this crazy group that take
off their own limbs and their heads for
fun I guess what is acceptable because
it fits in this world plus the songs fun
so I think if you can dial into the
headspace
I think there's anything wrong with that
scene and there's just so much stuff all
over the place the the the waffles
telling them to beware and I was like
just stop we're not gonna listen to you
when I was like oh please I've been said
it for such a long time there's so much
personality and everything actually
there's a specific moment that really
made me be amazed at the level of
thought and articulation put into these
puppets in these performances and I mean
this was something I realize it was
probably 20-something rewatching it when
it this really struck me maybe I've been
watching it forever I knew it was there
but it's with the doorknobs that the the
knockers rather which is another great
scene so much personality and you've got
the one with the ring to his ears the
one who can't really hear very well and
he has this one line you know after the
other characters didn't say something
good no good can't hear you and that
sniff he does that this and and like the
face moves appropriately it contracts
like it it does a sharp intake and it's
a puppet it's a it's a puppet with no
life except what a performer gives it
and they take that extra moment to give
it a given this dismissive inhale like
that much like with when you're watching
animation anything that you want you see
done in animation there's no such thing
as the little thing that an actor just
does naturally that makes it feel more
real it has to be thought of and put in
there on purpose it's very much the same
with puppets if a puppet is not been
articulated in a way to do a certain
movement
it just can't do it if they didn't think
that it would ever do that it won't do
that if the puppeteer doesn't think to
give it that little extra motion on
something it won't do it all of this has
to be done consciously by the people
making that to me is such a level of
artistry and thought and just inhabiting
this this art form it's amazing but I
know what you're waiting for
I've danced around it enough let's talk
about David Bowie and jerath I first so
long this this wasn't it probably still
is my definitive definitive image of
David Bowie probably always will be and
I think it is for a lot of people around
my age and he there is no word to
describe David Bowie in this role and
jerath has a character besides just cool
it's a bizarre eighties poofed up hair
kind of cool but damn it it's cool he's
just he's effortless and he's swaggering
and he's oddly intimidating at times and
yet and strangely enticing and I have a
suspicion that he caused a maturation
awakening in many of you er and possibly
a sense of confusion for many folks
probably I would say definitely more
than any other character in a PG movie I
would say arguably more than any other
character put the film maybe second to
Tim Curry as Frank inverter in Rocky
Horror but it's uh it's it's right up
there like I don't care who you are you
look at that you're just like I will
never look away from this guy and yes
the balls yeah I'm not even gonna dwell
on that because as a kid I didn't really
know this and as an adult I kind of like
I kind of shrug shrug it off I just is
him he is magnetic whether your eyes are
magically drawn to
his face or his crotch whatever he's
magnetic regardless but the thing is
it's it's not just a matter of stun
casting a great fit of performer to
character that is here but I actually do
think jerath is a fascinating character
if you really pay attention on what's
going on with him
because there's a certain sense of
obligation to him there's a certain
sense of weariness a certain sense of
almost desire to rebel there's a line
that he has towards the end that I've
always latched on to in my mind as being
the definitive jerath line and it shapes
what I think of this character which is
he says that he's been generous and Sara
says what have you done that's generous
he says everything everything that
you've wanted I have done you ask the
child be taken I took him you coward
before me I was frightening
I have reordered time I've turned the
world upside down and I've done it all
for you I am exhausted from living up to
your expectations of me that lie
especially that end I am exhausted from
living up to your expectations of me
that line fascinates me
this is somebody who in a way is playing
a part he knows what his role in this
story is and he's playing it and
possibly even taking enjoyment out of it
at points but ultimately he's doing this
because it's what he's supposed to do
and there's part of him that's exhausted
by that and given my attraction to this
kind of fantasy where we don't overly
explain everything I'm fine with not
knowing exactly how all this works but
if you want to go head can in places
you've got on any number of ways to go
maybe he just simply has a meta
awareness that this is a story for this
girl and his role is to be the villain
and he's going to play that role
maybe he's actually going a little extra
for Sarah because there does seem to be
a bit of a push-pull possibly attraction
I'm not sure I necessarily want to go
there like because it implies the sexual
thing but there's a longing in him you
like you especially with with a song
like within you which is the
the song that he sings during a whole MC
escher scene which ahaha awesome weird
trippy scene and you know just this
sense of he is somehow intrigued by
Sarah and yet at the same time is
frustrated that even has to do this
there's a terrific push-pull going on
internally with this character but I'm
not even sure I fully understand and I'm
pretty sure I can't properly articulate
but I love it and the thing is I tried
to read something like there was some
sequel or possibly prequel stuff done
like there was a manga or somebody I
tried flipping through it but it started
to delve more into jerath I'm like I
don't know like I want I want more of
him I want to see more of him but I
don't want him explained I love this the
contradictory nature of the things that
he says and the things that he does and
I just find that intriguing I don't I
don't want to know the ins and outs of
that I think the level we get in this
film is perfect I actually think a fair
amount of credit needs to go to Terry
Jones for the script because I don't
know if he gives as much
sort of recognition as he deserves for
his contribution to this film and I have
a feeling he was the one who brought
that kind of alice in wonderland' let's
just let's keep things not tethered down
to logic kind of sensibility to it
because it is a little bit Monty Python
a skin that weighs like this this feels
like it makes sense in the moment does
it make logical sense absolutely not but
who cares so I want to give
acknowledgement to him for that because
again I don't think he gets enough of it
the music Viv's the songs obviously
David Bowie did those but even the the
score which is Trevor Jones
who also did the music for Dark Crystal
his the the music is it it's very 80s
its kind of synthesized or heavy but I
enjoy it too I I think I think it adds
to this and it's it plays the right
things at the right moments it just this
this movie is such for me is such a
complete package in terms of amazing
puppetry terrific designs courtesy of
Bride
crowd who also did the conceptual
designs for Dark Crystal Jim Henson
really at the top of his game a great
script the kind of fantasy that I love
but can't get a lot of there is
especially on film there really is the
push within fantasy too especially these
days but to have the more grounded it
has to make sense thing that's you know
your Lord of the Rings you're Game of
Thrones and those are good and I enjoy
those but I have a real soft spot for
you know don't cross toadstool rings
because it's bad luck you know and not
because of any logical reason because
that's fairy tale logic you know I love
this I love Legend I I loved Pan's
Labyrinth
you know and because I there aren't many
places I can go that give me that that
kind of feel that this is just how this
story works field because I I enjoy that
I'd like when a story asks that of me
and has the faith in me as a viewer as a
faith in my level of this is willful
suspension of disbelief to just allow me
to go with it because I will maybe not
everybody does but I do and I love it
and I love this movie and I think
that'll wrap up this one labyrinth why
it's awesome why it's awesome to me have
you seen it what are your thoughts on it
whatever they are drop something down in
the comments let's talk about it there's
stuff to do like why can subscribe and
support me on patreon and all that stuff
links for everything are down in the
description plus links at the tail-end
during the credits until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]